[Music]
so I'm going to take about a question I
asked in the summer of 2001 that made me
nearly thirty million dollars from oh
one till today so here's what it listen
it's summer of old one I'm in a terrible
place financially I've got nothing going
on my expedition was taking back I'm
driving a car I can barely fit in and
I'm trying to become a financial adviser
with Morgan Stanley beam with I'm a
serious seven new broker 21 22 years old
trying to get this thing going but I
have no client nothing my mother's back
in Iran my dad's a cashier at a 99-cent
store and 99-cent store customers can't
afford a quarter million dollars for
Morgan stew anything with us I said this
I won during that summer time and I
email text called everybody I knew who
was somewhat credible and I asked him
one question here's what it was how can
I help you during the summer I asked
everybody how can I help you how can I
help you not how can I sell you not what
can I service you with not how can make
money off you how can I help you I just
kept asking this question and so one of
my friends at that time everybody kept
telling me can help me hear it can help
me can help you one of the friends that
I had a good relationship with his son
just called me two days ago it's
interesting he says my son's been in
prison for 7 years
no one's visiting him I wouldn't mind if
you go visit my son so I said ok no
problem how can I do a background check
a month and have all this stuff and I go
into this done I visit a son I come back
and my relationship with this person
went to hold up all over one to his
birth he gave me a referral that through
this one referral he gave over the years
introduced me to contact alleged 30
million dollars
so during this summer whether you're a
teenager entrepreneur whether you're
somebody that just graduated high school
your mom and dad or nagging saying how
come you don't have a job whether you
just become a CPA you don't know how to
find clients whether you just got your
real estate right and you just got your
insurance license you just started a
business no matter what you're doing
that has to do with business go to all
the uncles the best friends dad that
stuff that's cool your former boss your
principal in school and just ask you one
question hey Bob football as well I just
look I just want to reach out to an ask
your question how can I help you during
the summer let me know how I can help
during summer how can I go about helping
you doing something you will be amazed
at how many ways you can help them up
and in return it will always remember
that you went out of your way to helping
them on and this doesn't guarantee that
everybody's come back and going to give
you a rapport that's going to make you
thirty million dollars all this other
stuff but business and life is all about
contacts and connections and
relationships you may be introduced this
summer to one contact that can
completely change the last year of
business in your life forever to come so
go ask the question how can I help you
[Music]